ومع تزايد المخاوف من ان الصين قد تشن
غزوا على تايوان في السنوات المقبله يعمل
الجيش الامريكي على توسيع نطاق وجوده في
اسيا والمحيط الهادئ وتعزيز قدرات حلفائه
في المنطقه ايضا مفتاح استراتيجيه رضع
الصين عن اي تحركات عدوانيه هو التركيز
المتزايد على تعزيز قدرات الجيوش
الامريكيه والجيوش المتحالفه على العمل
بشكل فعال معا وزير الدفاع الاستراليه قال
انه يريد ان تصل درجه التنسيق الى حد
تبادل المعدات العسكريه والتي يقول خبراء
الدفاع انها يمكن ان تتضمن استخداما
متكررا للاسلحه والمعدات وامدادات الذخيره
لبعضهم البعض وتنسيق اللوجيسيات وسلاسل
التوريد بكفاءه اكبر الولايات المتحده
تخطط ايضا لزياده وجودها في شمال استراليا
وفي نقطه انطلاق محتمله لاي صراع في
المحيطين الهندي والهادئ حيث يتدرب مشاه
البحريه الامريكيه مع الجيش الاسترالي
وتعليقا على الخطوه الراميه الى اندماج
الجيشين الامريكي والاسرائيلي قال صحيفه
جلوبال تايمز الصينيه التي تديرها الدوله
ان ذلك سيؤدي الى ان يصبح الجيش الاستراني
مجرد عنصر في اطار خطه لمن وصفتهم
بالمسؤولين الاسرائيليين الامريكيين الذين
يدعون الاحتفاظ بالسياده على جيشهم
لكن الصين لا تبدو انها تتجه للتهدئه
بالمناسبه يظهر ذلك جليا مع بدايه الولايه
الثالثه للرئيس جيفنج الذي غير وجوه
وزارته الهادئه باخرين من معسكر الصقور
فمثلا اليوم تم تاكيد تعيين الجنرال كوزير
جديد للدفاع في البلاد وهو من المدرجين
على قوائم العقوبات الامريكيه بسبب شراء
اسلحه روسيه ويذكر ان وزير الدفاع الصيني
الجديد هو من رواد تحديث جيش التحرير
الشعبي الصيني ايضا وزير الخارجيه المعين
حديثا اظهر تحولا في وجد دبلوماسيه
الهادئه ووزير الخارجيه السابقين فوزير
الخارجيه الجديد في اول مؤتمر الصحفي له
قبل اسبوع قال ان الصراع والمواجهه مع
الولايات المتحده امر لما فر منه اذا لم
تغيره واشنطن سياسته
[موسيقى]
وزير الدفاع الصيني الجديد عهد قد ينبئ
بتوترات مع الولايات المتحده
صحيح انه يطابق الصفات المفترضه للحزب
الشيوعي الصيني وحظي بموافقه اعلى هيئه
تشريعيه في الصين لكنه مدرج في قائمه
العقوبه الامريكيه منذ عام 2018
حيث تتهمه واشنطن بالتعاون العسكري مع
موسكو حينما كان يتراس مديريه الاسلحه
علما بانه شغل منصب رئيس قسم تطوير
المعدات وقاد قوه الدعم الاستراتيجي للجيش
الصيني وامضى ثلاثه عقود من الزمن في مركز
شيت شانج لاطلاق الاقمار الصناعيه ما يعني
ان الصعود ليشانغ فو يعكس تطورا غير مسبوق
لمؤسسه الفضاء
اذ ستواصل بكين منحل اولويه للفضاء في
اجنده ولايه شيجين بنج الثالثه وسيمثل
وجود وزير الدفاع الجديد عمل المحفزا
لاستحداث تكنولوجيات قتاليه ينافس بها
امريكا